樱花 Поэтому是好事
樱花
哈喽哈喽早上好早上好
早上好姐妹们
早上好
热死了
好好好嘞
这个女性的温暖水多吗
早上好早上好姐妹们
来过款了过款
过款了
早上好早上好
来看一下这一款新款的这个连衣裙
新款的一款连衣裙
是一个威灵雪纺的面料
然后这个前面是一个威灵
有几个小包裤的这个是
领裤的话
它是一个木耳边的一个领裤
袖口有一个小纽扣
胶上是全松紧
裙子摆着的一个裙
来这个裙
胸围
胸围92102
来这个长度
长度是118的一个长度
118的长度
这个咱们有要的扣
8989扣8扣8
89扣个8扣个8
这个是个新款
新款
然后这个面料的话
它上面这个小碎花
还有这个
就这一点点
bling bling的这个亮晶晶的
来这个89
高货高货
一万一万几的一个吊牌架
一万大几的一个吊牌架
我忘了一万几了
这个吊牌没有了
来这个89
89扣8扣8
89扣个8
Azp9
・・・・ ・・・ ・・・・。
来. 这一款
这个是一个小短袖
肩膀上有两个小透明的小 곤 давайте买 Это一个小短袖
肩膀上有两个小透明的
两个小裤子 T partnership hopefully
扣子的话可以打开的这一块
棉灰纺的一个小短袖来看一下胸围
胸围的话是104108
104108长度63
来这个9块9块
扣3扣3这一个
9块9块扣个3扣个3
9元扣3扣3
因为我们下下那边也
那我没注意他们
9块钱9块钱扣个3
早上好早上好
来这一款
这个是一个黑色的一个小背心
黑色的这一款背心尺码大的这个这个
嗯螺纹的螺纹的一个背心
来这个尺寸看一下胸围
胸围是106126长度是67
这个9块9块扣个3
9块9块扣3扣3
这个9块9块扣3扣3
这个9块9块扣3扣3扣3
背心背心螺纹的一款背心
9块9块
扣3扣3
9元扣个3扣个3
9块钱扣3扣3
来这个这个背心
这个好像就是一件了
购品那天谁要的这个
就这个咔色就是一件这个背心
那天有人要我没找到不知道放哪去了
你看今天就出来了
袋子是可以调解的这个
嗯可以外穿的一个背心
后面腰上是有松紧
然后有腰带胸围
胸围是8686的拉伸102
86的拉伸102来这个长度
长度是50长度50
这个29扣5
29块扣5扣5这一块
29扣个5早上好早上好快乐999
你来啦早上好这个给他留着
我忘了走几天谁用了
了这个背心
哈萨
9块9块
过到
嗯一脚嘎啦那堆了
没有
这一大堆在这放着你咋知道
一脚嘎啦有啊
嗯那一堆开子过了一脚
那一堆开子过了
昨天都过了好几袋子了
我看他们俩
来这个这个是一个
雪纺雪纺
里面的话是有内里
内里有人绵35就是65
外面是一个雪纺
那边都开始过了
今天呢几袋子都拿那边的过的
来这个胸围胸围1104
1104来这个长度长度63这一包不是
昨天过了几袋对啊
来9块9块扣3扣3
这一袋不是
9块钱扣3
9块扣3这个全9
这一户两件了这个是
有希望了有希望了
离你的那个越来越近了
来这个这个是
这个是男士的一个短袖
出来了一个
这个属于一个啥颜色
杏色的不灰色灰色
一个灰色一个蓝色
男士的一个短袖
这个我留了两件
我留了两件
来这个胸围看一下
胸围的话是110到120
110120的胸围来这个长度
长度是75
9块钱扣5扣5
我留的就留一个灰色一个蓝色
留了给我爷爷穿了
这个老爸也能穿爷爷也能穿这个很好
不分
不分年龄都能穿老公也能穿这个面料很垂
很舒服的这个
9块钱9块钱原来是29的
来这个蓝色
这个是一个蓝色蓝色的这个是
一个蓝色蓝色的一个短袖
一个灰色一个蓝色
很好穿这个面料
有这种冰冰凉凉的感觉了
我们就要其他两件
您的选择
我们就要两件
咱们的选择
我们要点这个
这个颜色
来这个胸围
胸围是110120
110120的胸围来长度
长度73
来这个9块9块
扣3扣3
9块扣个3
这个是个蓝色的
有冰冰凉凉的这种触感
男士男士可以穿
男士可以穿
老公也能穿
老爸也能穿
你看都很舒服
这个面料滑溜溜的
9块钱扣3扣3
这两个的话都是L尺码的
两件都是L尺码的
这个9块钱扣3扣3
原来是都是29的
现在全放9块了
9块钱9块钱
来这一款
这个小苹果圈你晒涂了
晒涂了是一个蓝色
这个是个黑色
黑色和黄色条纹的一个短袖
男女都能穿
来这个胸围
宣言品颇是110 120
长度70
9块9块扣1扣1
9块钱扣个1扣个1
黑色和黄色条纹的这一款
9块钱
9块钱扣1扣1
9块扣个1
9块9块扣1扣1
来这一款
这个是编了一个塞欧的
塞欧男士的一个短袖
后面的话是有胶印字母
胶印图案的这一款
来这个胸围
胸围120 130 140
130 140的胸围
来这个长度
长度77
这个9块扣8
9块扣个8扣个8
这个塞欧塞欧的
9块钱扣8扣8
9块钱扣个8扣个8
9块9块
来这一款
这一包都短袖了这一包
这个是一个细线针织的一个开衫
有扣眼儿
缺扣子
有扣眼儿少扣子的这个
那细线棉线的一个针织
就这种这个早上先卖的可好了
这一款
有扣眼儿少扣子回去装几个扣就可以了
棉线的一个
细线针织的
胸围106134
106134的胸围
长度是62的
这个给你们9块9块
扣个2扣个2
9块钱扣个2
有扣眼儿缺扣子
棉线的
细线针织
看见没
棉线一个针织薄的很细细的这个线
9块9块
扣2扣2而已
9元扣个2扣个2而已
这一包都是短袖
离不过了啊
9块钱
来这一款
这个小上衣啊
这个是一个学访的
学访的这一件
圆领圆领领口这里打了几个
整
然后这样的一个床袖吧应该是
来这个胸围
胸围是102104
102104啊胸围
长度长度是53
长度53
这个9块钱
扣3扣3
9块扣个2
扣个3
孤品孤品啊这一款
9块9块
扣3扣3
9元扣个3
是一个米色
米色学访的
9块钱
扣3扣3
哇这个裤子还有呢
这个孤品哇这个
哈伦裤哈伦裤
看没这有一条哈伦裤
前面有抽绳后半边松拧的这个
卡鞋子两边有鞋扎口袋
腰围66
6到86
66 86
腿围106116
裆长34
裤长90
这个裤子后面有一点点粗纱线
有一条粗纱线这里
还买一个线接口的地方线疙瘩
和抽丝一样的
有个线疙瘩好像抽丝一样这么一点点
还有一截粗纱线
这个9块钱
不介意的扣5扣5啊
9块9块
扣个5扣个5啊
扣5扣5
9块钱给你们了哈伦裤卡其色的这个
9块9块
扣扣5
9块钱扣个5
来这个卫衣
这个卫领卫领的一款卫衣这个地方是有一个毛巾袖的这个
来这个胸围
胸围的话是106到128
106128来长度长度是71啊
这个要的9块9块给你们扣9扣9
9块钱扣个9
卫衣卫衣
毛圈棉的里面是毛圈的一个棉婚纺
毛圈的这个
9块了9块9块
扣9扣9
9块钱扣扣9
还有一个南瓜裙呢你看看
还有一个南瓜裙
面料可舒服了这个
这个那个叫什么
什么什么什么节的手传你看
南瓜裙
扣好了一块连一圈
来这个胸围胸围88到120
88120的胸围长度
长度是106长度106
这个19块1919扣6扣6
1919扣6弹力都很大很大的这个
看吧底下是一个雪黄的呢
上面是有弹力的这个上衣啊
标的是一个M码后面是有个影像
拉链
1919给你们
扣1扣1呀
19块扣个1